Bats are more like us
than you would think,
because they live a really long time
and that’s really unusual
for a mammal of that size.
So a mammal of that size
usually lives one to two years
and bats can live up to 40 years
which is amazing.
They have a really interesting repair
mechanism for their DNA,
so they can repair all the DNA that
is broken and they never get cancer.
Bats are very resilient animals.
They also have
a number of adaptations
that make them very good at
surviving in harsh environments.
Bats use loads of different senses.
So bats use their eyes,
so they're not blind,
but they also use
sense of smell.
So they have big smell
regions of their brains
when they need to find food.
The primary sense
that many bats use
is echolocation,
or sonar in human terms.
Although the bats have been using
these signals for 50 million years,
we've been using them
for maybe 100 years.
We also need to be
operating on our senses.
We have to operate on our
gut feeling a lot of the time.
Jungles are probably the best place
for having to use
your senses constantly
because they're hot,
they're humid, dark.
So you're almost feel a bit
like a bat, very claustrophobic.
And you have to be aware
of the little changes.
So when things go quiet, potentially
there is a predator in the area.
Bats, very often,
live in very large colonies.
Very often these colonies contain
millions of individuals.
One of the largest aggregations
of mammals on the planet
is a bat roost
in Texas in Bracken Cave.
We don’t really know
how many there are
but it's between 10 and 20
million bats that live there.
This colonial way of life
has several advantages.
So bats can keep each other warm
and reduce energy costs
by huddling together.
Another advantage of being in a group
is it reduces your individual risk
of being eaten by a predator.
So bats live in large communities,
they have to get on
with lots of other people
and on expedition
we can be in a large team.
So building relationships,
sustaining those relationships,
developing systems
for living in a community,
generally away from normal
society, bit like the bats,
and therefore we have
to develop our own ways
of supporting each other,
looking after each other,
teamwork,
using the collective mind
to be aware of danger
or to enable us to actually do
the tasks that we're going to do.
Bats don’t just care about
their own blood relatives,
they care about other individuals
in their wider community too.
They form these buddy pairs
and if you don’t find
a meal for that night
you can ask your buddy to share
what they have for that night
and then the next night
you can reciprocate.
So it's called reciprocal altruism,
one of the very few examples
of reciprocal altruism
in mammals in the entire world.
So bats are often covered in quite
large numbers of parasites.
The bats get rid of parasites,
in part, by grooming.
Not only do they
groom themselves
but very often they do
something called allogrooming
where individuals
groom one another
proving social bonds among
individuals in colonies.
Bats are well known
for their personal hygiene,
their levels of personal hygiene.
The dark, dank bits need to be
cleaned on a regular basis,
and also you need to be aware
of your cleanliness,
particularly around other people.
It can ruin relationships,
particularly if you're sharing a
tent with them for a period of time,
and your ability to continue
doing the expedition.